here we go hang on Mike this is Leonardo
he's our fearless leader but light him
up
by elves like a cuddly teddy bear if
they cut the teddy bears we're
incredibly violent that's how are you
I'm a triple threat brains brawn and a
dazzling personality
guys I got a lead on what's going on
good for you Oh y'all got jokes huh
etiquette most things are pretty awesome
huh
what are you superheroes
we're four brothers who hate bullies and
love this city - you're seriously three
four teenagers could say the whole world
very well as long as you work together
as brothers you shall always succeed
nice never say goodbye this is awkward
really eg 13 what is the most important
trait for the ninja speed stealth and
precision
doesn't seem so tough
we rap
oh well starts June 3rd
what's happening out there Donnie I
don't know it doesn't look good
gear up guys
Wow
my recite bullies on the bus I think
it's very fight what button there a
million buttons
what are you superheroes just four
brothers who hate bullies
and love this city well this never works
out well for you
okay so one question you do guys like a
thing I'm looking for Aaron Lord but we
could work with that
thank you
bring you back the Mohawk good for you
Oh y'all got jokes huh
recording with the turtles when
something bad happens you want to be
with the turtles
well well fun what's your name Casey
Jones did you guys like a thing
who are these guys if you want to go
down swinging these guys hit harder than
anyone trying to decide between Pocky
and a lunatic vigilante definitely
vigilante rid of you Gigi what's
happening out there Donnie I don't know
just four brothers who love this city
I'm looking for errand boys
bringing back the Mohawk good for you
y'all got jokes huh Stacey jealous did
you guys like a
yeah well this film is not yet rated
I'm so tough